en los vídeos anteriores describimos
este escenario en donde la compañía
quiere adquirir a la compañía ve y lo
van a hacer mediante la creación de 2
millones en acciones y darles estos 2
millones en acciones a los accionistas
de la compañía de y los accionistas de
la compañía vez a su vez otorgarán todas
sus acciones por lo que habrá un
intercambio de acciones por un millón en
acciones de la compañía ve o con base en
las acciones por persona cada persona
dará una de sus acciones de la compañía
ve y a cambio recibirá dos acciones de
la compañía y recibirán dos acciones de
la compañía
y quedamos que todas las personas están
seguras de que esa transacción se va a
llevar a cabo en teoría cualquiera que
sea el precio de bbva al real doble de
ellos pues la gente sabrá que cuando la
transacción se lleve a cabo se cambiara
una acción debe por dos acciones de a
bueno ahora qué pasaría en la situación
en la que ve no se comercializa al doble
de a esa es la curva hipotética cuando
ve vale el doble de a
qué pasa si no se hace esta negociación
en estos términos
qué pasa si las acciones de b se
negocian vamos a ponerlo en otro color
qué tal si se van a comprar o vender por
debajo del doble de las acciones de a
bueno este caso podría darse cuando
existen personas que piensen que esta
transacción no se va a dar por lo que no
están dispuestos a pagar el precio
premium para ver digamos que ustedes
trabajan para un fondo de cobertura que
tiene un modelo un modelo matemático y
tienen siete información en donde
ustedes saben de hecho están 100%
seguros de que esta transacción se va a
llevar a cabo y que definitivamente se
va a llevar a cabo en esos términos
2 millones en acciones de a por un
millón en acciones de ver ahora ustedes
podrían verse tentados a decir bueno
porque no compro acciones debe pues
finalmente van a subir de precio pero
qué tal si se desploma todo el mercado
qué pasaría si las acciones de acai eran
así y las acciones de bt también caen
ustedes no quieren comprar las acciones
debe pensar lo que simplemente van a
subir porque si la transacción de verdad
va a ocurrir entonces me va a valer el
doble exactamente de lo que valgan las
acciones de a la solución es establecer
una pareja comercial aquí lo que se hace
es que si ustedes creen que esta
transacción se va a realizar ustedes
pueden comprar una acción vamos a
escribirlo aquí abajo ustedes pueden
comprar
una acción debe
así que compran una acción de ve y luego
hacer una venta corta una venta corta de
dos acciones de a la razón por la que
esto va a funcionar y sólo funciona si
ustedes están seguros de que la
transacción se va a llevar a cabo es
porque en este momento dos acciones de a
serán en cualquier momento ya que ve
está un poquito por debajo del doble de
a dos acciones de a van a valer más que
una acción de ver cuando hacen una venta
corta de dos acciones de a vamos a
imaginar que estamos en este punto de
acá que estoy señalando justo en la
fecha en donde se ha hecho el anuncio
cuando se tiene una venta corta de dos
acciones de a vamos a obtener 60 dólares
obtenemos 60 dólares recordemos que la
venta cortes cuando ustedes toman
prestadas las existencias de otra
persona venden estas existencias y más
adelante tendrán que volverlas a comprar
por lo que ustedes le deben a alguien
dos acciones sino secciones de hace y
negocian en 60 dólares las acciones debe
van a estar un poquito por abajo de ese
precio nos va
55 dólares es un descuento comparado con
el valor de tus acciones
así que claramente aquí tenemos 60 m los
55 tenemos un valor neto de 5 dólares y
asumiendo que la transacción va a
suceder en una fecha futura cuando se
cierre la transacción esta acción debe
que tenemos la vamos a poder cambiar por
dos acciones de a aquí obtenemos el
doble del valor de las acciones de a y
podemos usar eso para cubrir nuestra
venta corta usamos esto para cubrir
nuestra venta corta y nos quedamos con
cinco dólares y aunque hay un pequeño
riesgo de que la transacción no se
realice pero asumiendo que si se lleva a
cabo
ustedes obtuvieron cinco dólares gratis